foreign
celebrates her daughter dreams Pre-K
graduation alongside the Kardashians one
year after their Court battle yep Kylie
Jenner Khloe Kardashian and Chyna all
had reasons to celebrate this week their
daughters stormy true and dream
graduated from pre-kindergarten together
isn't that crazy Kylie posted this pic
with her first born on Wednesday while
Coco shared a series of sweet images
including this snap of the cousin Trio
writing yesterday was a big day my sweet
angel girl graduated from pre-k no I'm
not okay my favorite part about being a
mom I mean it's so corny but it's just
like no matter how tired you are
whatever you just it's complete Bliss
and Chyna who shares her six-year-old
daughter with her ex Rob Kardashian
marked her little girl's big milestone
posting these balloon filled snaps to
her story I'm just feeling blessed right
now and being a good mother of of course
it's been one year since China's
defamation lawsuit against Rob and his
family came to an end the mother of my
brother's daughter is suing me Kylie
Kimberly and my mom for defamation and
interference with the contract she is
saying that the Rob and China show
didn't get a second season because we
interfered with it not because they
weren't in a relationship anymore
back in May 2022 a jury decided that no
monetary damages should be awarded to
China the trial was discussed on the
famous family's Hulu series and cameras
were rolling as they received the
verdict
[Music]
since then China seemingly turned a
corner she's been baptized and in the
name of a holy ghost was Faith a part of
your journey before now no this was my
first time ever being baptized
and she's been documenting her journey
to Wellness on social media reversing
the Cosmetic work she had done on her
breasts and backside and the best
decisions I could have done in a very
long time China who now goes by her
birth name Angela White also dissolves
the fillers from her face I'm just I'm
ready to get back to Angela like Blac
Chyna like Blacktown is Blac Chyna you
know what I mean and I feel like I've
outgrown that and it's just time for
like a change and she shared the process
of having a demonic tattoo removed from
her hip I just don't want anything
negative or demonic on my body anymore
China even revealed she got rid of her
only fans page which has reportedly made
her hundreds of millions of dollars and
in March she showed her support for
Rob's Sister Kim Kardashian rocking a
shirt featuring the reality star posing
for Dolce and Gabbana I wore this shirt
today because I wanted to support Kim
thank you yeah she did a collaboration
with Dolce and I I respect it you know
and his dreams on teams so and back in
April Chyna said she's just focused on
bettering herself It's All About Me amen
you feel me and I like that I like that
a lot actually
[Music]